Ah, well, alright then.
I seem to be
*jumpscare* hEYYYYYY
Hello everybody my name is Markiplier :>
and welcome to They Come At Poop Time.
NOo don't click away...
This game is *laughs* for real.
If you guys were watching
the double feature of horror that I did a wil- little bit ago
this may look like a giant pile a shit
but, *laughs again* beneath that shit
is a nugget- uh
*sigh of self disappointment*
I'm not really selling this very well am I (nope)
Okay, all of my bad description of this game aside,
we're gonna go into the (spooky) forest
because I'm not goin' for completionist route here
and I've already done the home one
and I wanna go into the forest
to give a little bit of sense of scare.
*reading instructions* There's three enemies. One above you in a tree,
two are out in the woods,
*stops reading* your tryin' to take a poop
THEY WON'T LET YOU
*brave markimoo* LET'S GET INTO THIS (YEAH X3)
oh *brave Mark gone* OH HI
*nervous laugh* whahahyyy
I didn't read the instructionsss
I don't know how ta beat you
can you just leave me to my poo and go *laughs nervously again* awayy...
So who else is here?
Oh look,
you gonna be creepin down aren'tcha
Oh boy  (I gotta keycard its the wrong one)
Oh oh wha- I wa (you alright there bud)
well I-I *flashes light*
wh-  hEY STOP!!!
Don't come any closer!!
Try-trying to poop here!
Just trying... trying to do my thi-
What are you...?
I don't know what to do about you!
Wha-
It's a game of Red Light Green Light up here,
and it's a game of Yes Poo No Poo over here!
What are you...?
Stop!  How do I stop you!?
UrrRAugh
Okay, well.
*Flashlight Spam*
That's REALLY doing it for him!
Oh, hi!
What the fuuuuu...
...uuUAGH!
Hey!  Hey!
Wha-
I don't know what to do 'bout this situation!
Oh, this seems bad...
Uh, well.  Alright then.
I seem to be-
***JUMPSCARE***
Ayeee!  What the fuck!?
I'm now constipooted.
So that's what I mean about this game is *laughs* surprisingly good!
It's surprisingly good, okay.
You know what, I'm gonna go back to the menu and I might actually read what I need to do, okay.
"Tree enemy is always crawling down towards you."
"Make it crawl back up by looking at him with the flashlight."
"Zombies will frequently spawn."
"They will slowly be walking..."
Oh, "Pick a rock up from the rock pile and throw it at him"?
I don't need to poop this badly! (yes you do ;p)
I need to do what Chica does, and she sprints before she takes a poop!
Okay, so Scarecrow... it'll appear, I'll see him in a tree,
and when he disappears from the tree, I'll turn the flashlight off.
*Mark chuckles*
Oh, this, this seems difficult.
Alright, but let's do this, okay.
So, lookin' up at you...
Where's my rock pile?
Alright, there's my rock pile.
I got a rock.
Can I throw it at you?
Didn't do NUTHIN.
But you're gonna take that away with you, aren't ya?
UUUghhH.
Oh man, the mechanics of this one are fun.
Okay, where's zombo?
Oop, wait...
EhhhHH
Well, sorry about the terrible throw there.
I'll just wait 'til you get closer I guess.
Oh boy.
I'm gonna...
Oh!  Maybe I did get it.
EUUuuuhh.
Yeah.  Oh, that didn't get you at all.
Oh, eh.
nOoo!
My ROCK!
Oh, my ancestors are gonna be upset about that one.
Alright, I don't see the scarecrow anywhere,
but apparently I'm not-
Oohhhayyy.
I'm not nailing these zombos.
These zomBOZOs.
Oh, that didn't work at all.
Heyy, you're real close to me.
Ugh!
Sorry, terrible throws, I know!
Oh god, that's not...
Okay, well there's a scarecrow.
Hee
Oh, that's not good.
I'm gonna die one way or another here.
It looks like it's gonna be through that.
Scarecrow?  Okay, I see you there.
Oh shit.
Okay...
Ehh. Quick throw!  Ehh!
Uh ooh.  Ah!  I think...
UHHH, I don't like that!
AHHHHHHHHHH.
***JUMPSCARE***
FUCKING goddammit!
I'm now cOnstiPOOTED!
Alright, so the trick is...
Load up with a rock and just wait looking at the guy to get him up as much as possible
because that's going to be like the determining factor.
Alright YOU.
You get back up in that tree!
Don't think that you can get me a SPOOK.
I don't want a spook.
Maybe I can go by noise if they hear... *Mark chuckles*
If they're nice to me!
Yeah, yeah, you get up in there.
Alright, no one's there.
Yeah, you get... oh, you get UP in that tree.
How far away can you go up in that tree?
Let's find out.  Let's go for an adventure.
Yeah, that's right.
Oh, oh man.  Must be hard on your thighs to crawl backwards like that, but I don't care-
*Growling*
Well that's not good.
Hey!  Get out of here.
Okay, I already have a rock, idiot.
Well don't call me an idiot!
Okay.  This is dicey!  This legitimately dicey!
Like I gotta admit, they-
wwWWaUHh.
I don't like that.
*Growling* I can get you  in the dark!
Maybe.
Okay, I think... am I SAFE?  I think I'm safe.
I don't know what safe means in this poop NIGHTMARE!
Oh god.  Hey, don't do that.
I know I have a rock, I want to throw it at the guy!
Okay, alright, we're good.
Okay.
Alright.
Ah!  I can do this!
I can poop for realsies!
I'm gonna be able to poop!
In the woods.
I don't even think this is a toilet that I'm on, I think I'm just doing a wall squat by a goddamn tree here.
There is no toilet!  I'm trying to take a shit at the base of this tree.
Oh boy.
This is not ideal for me!
*weird fart noise*
Did I poop?
Was that me poopin'?
Was that a successful poop?
Nope!  I got 200 seconds left!
Okayyeeee.
I don't like this.
Ugh.  I don't know where to look!
Okay, Scarecrow is still there.
Ooh, uh, AIEEE!
Okay, alright, no point in looking up, so I might as well get the...
Okay, maybe like the darkness is the perfect opportunity.
Is he gone?  I don't know if he's gone.
EEE
Okay, alright.  I'm gonna assume he's gone.
I don't know when the gone-ness happens!
Uoooh.
Just like when I don't know when the gone-ness happens in my butt!
That means- I'm talkin' about poopin'!
Ehh god, ennmughgh.
My commentary really turns to shit when I'm in this game. (Pun intended?)
*Mark sobs*
It's even worse now.
Is that good or bad?
I think the stick breaking is them...is him going away?
I have no idea, but it's terrifying.
100 seconds of poop left.
Ugh, maybe this is just one big poop.
It's just taking me a long time.
I like how also they don't kill me, they just like interrupt my pooping process,
therefore I can't poop, and that's literally the only punishment here.
Alright.
Doodly doo.
No no no no.  Get back, get back up.
They're far enough... ooh, are they far enough away?
Oweeeyee!
Alright, okay.  I got this.
Yes, yes, yes and no.  Also no.
Yes and also no.
Yes and also no!
Eeee, UGH!
Oh!
Throw rocks!
Get ROCKED!!
Uhh!
Uhhh!
Am I good?
Okay, I think I'm good.
Yee, okay.
Get ROCKED!
Alright.
I think I'm gonna win this.
YES!  30 seconds of poop!
Get me that sweet finish! *Mark chuckles*
Oh, I don't think I brought any toilet paper.
I think I'm gonna be in trouble!
That's right.  You don't wanna be near--
Something's about to happen, you better crawl back up in that tree.
What about me poopin' draws all these monsters out of the woods?
Huh?
What kind of curse is this?
What kind of horrible demon cursed me to have poop demons come after me in the monstrous dark?
And also why am I in the... I think I'm-
YAAAAY! :D
I pooped!!
*Mark cracks up*
*Toilet flushes*
WHAT DID I FLUSH!?
What did I just flush?  Did I flush the tree!?
You know, I wouldn't put it past me in this weird world that I live in!
Anyway, that is "They Come at Poop Time".
I don't think I'm gonna do a completionist of this,
but goddamn is that funny.
Alright, so anyway, thank you everybody so much for watching.
Let me know what you thought of "They Come at Poop Time".
I'm gonna put a link to the game down in the description, or the comments-
errr the DESCRIPTION below...
and then you can play it for yourself for all the other levels!
So thanks everybody for watching, and as always, I will see you in the next video!
Bye bye!